[Music]
all right coming up on 608 on your
Wednesday morning you know most of our
driving you crazy conversations are
about the present and future Nightmares
on roads all over town but we're going
to take a trip back in time
starting Friday the Clark County Museum
down in the Southeast Valley opening a
new exhibit called laying out Las Vegas
a look back at the pioneer days of
Southern Nevada and how land surveyors
helped pave the way to today there'll be
plenty for map nerds to enjoy it also
photos of the tough conditions back in
the day as well as the equipment used to
help build this community
not to mention the fancy mannequins and
the historically accurate fashions
there's Mr surveyor hey they're going to
have a reception at the Museum Friday
evening from 6 p.m to 8. the exhibit is
scheduled to run into early October we
have a link to the museum in the online
version of this store it's on our
website 8newsnow.com just click traffic
then driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and please put down that phone
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com